الهاتف يرن::
سيدي الرئيس هناك مواطنون روس
يعنفون في هذه المنطقة،،
يرد أعطني مسؤول السفارة،،،
بوتين يتحدث
إذا تم المساس بأي مواطن روسي
أو تعرض لأي أذى، فإن ردنا سيكون قاسيا
وأغلق الهاتف...
وهنا يقولها بغضب
لقد طفح الكيل!!
لن يكون لديكم وقت لترمش عيونكم)
لكن مهلا ماذا بك أيها الدب الروسي الشرس،
ما الذي يزعجك؟
ولماذا كل هذا القسوة؟
وما الذي تنوي فعله حقا؟
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يرد:
(فهمتم أم لم تفهموا!
سنغزو أوكرانيا عسكريا
إن لم تنصاعوا لطلباتنا،)
بوتين  أيضا يلوح بقوته النووية
ليرعب حلف الناتو،
وإن لم يستجب الحلف
فسيرى ردا قويا وحاسما،
هكذا أعلنها الدب الروسي،
يبدو أنه لا يمزح يا سادة!!!
حلف الناتو ينوه باستخدام البند الخامس،
لكن لسان حال بوتين يقول وماذا بعد؟
أرونا أقصى ما تستطيعون فعله!..،
واتصال هاتفي من فرنسا
وآخر من الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية،
جميعهم يريدون حلا ديبلوماسيا،
فما الذي يجري على الأرض اليوم؟
فلاديمير بوتين رئيس روسيا يقول،
كل ما فعله من يمكن تسميتهم بشركائنا
(الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية)
في السنوات السابقة،
بزعم الحفاظ على مصالحهم وأمنهم المفترض،
دون أي تفويض من مجلس الأمن الدولي
قصفوا يوغسلافيا، لقد دمروا البلاد هناك،
لكن لماذا قصفوها أصلا؟
ومن أعطى لأمريكا الحق لضرب عاصمة أوروبية؟
ولماذا دخل الأمريكان إلى العراق؟
قالوا أسلحة دمار شامل هه،
لكنهم دمروا البلاد وأوجدوا
بؤرة للإرهاب هناك، وبعد ذلك
قالوا أخطأنا وخذلتنا المخابرات
ههههههههه،،
(أليس رائعا أن تدمر البلاد ثم تقول
خذلتنا المخابرات!!  يا للعجب)
وماذا عن سوريا هل دخلوها
بموافقة من مجلس الأمن الدولي؟
كلا، إنهم يتصرفون وفق أهوائهم!!!
فهل تعد تصريحات بوتين هذه
مؤشرا لتصعيد التوترات من جديد
مع الولايات المتحدة؟
وهل هي شرارة لاندلاع حرب بين الطرفين؟
(محاولة التهدئة)
اتصال هاتفي أجراه بايدن مع نظيره بوتين،
لمحاولة حل الأمور عبر الديبلوماسية،
دامت المكالمة أكثر من ساعة
بين تهديد ووعيد، أكد خلالها بايدن
أن واشنطن، ستفرض عقوبات سريعة
ومؤلمة على روسيا في حال غزوها لأوكرانيا،
وإن حدث الغزو فرد أمريكا
سيكون حاسما وسريعا،
وحذر بايدن أيضا من كلفة باهظة
وفورية ستكون نتاجا للغزو الروسي،
بايدن قال أيضا أن بلاده تسعى لحل سياسي
للأزمة ولكنها مستعدة لسيناريوهات أخرى
وبمشاركة من حلفائها وشركائها،،
رد الكرملين سريعا عقب هذا الاتصال الهاتفي،
وقال أن هذه التوجسات عبارة عن
هستيريا أمريكية وقد بلغت ذروتها،
فهذه تهديدات ذات مستويات عبثية،
وأضاف الكرملين أن بوتين تحدث مع بايدن
عن الملف الأمني وهو المحور الذي
تدور حوله الأزمة الحالية،
وعن الحلول والترتيبات لهذه الأزمة،،
واتفق الطرفان على مواصلة الحوار،
لكن تصريحات البيت الأبيض
تقول أن هذا الاتصال لم ينجم عنه شيء
ولازالت الأزمة تراوح مكانها،
بل أنها تزداد تعقيدا،،،
الرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون كان قد حاول أيضا
حل الموقف ديبلوماسيا،
وأجرى اتصالا هاتفي مع بوتين،
في محاولة فرنسية دؤوبة
لاحتواء الأزمة الروسية،
ومع تأكيد ماكرون أن أوروبا سترد
على أي تصعيد عسكري روسي
على أوكرانيا فإنه سيواصل مساعيه
للوصول لحل سياسي، فهل يفلح ماكرون
في ما عجزت عنه أمريكا والغرب؟
(الرد الروسي)
..
رد الرئيس بوتين كان واضحا،
فهو يلوح بقدرات بلاده النووية والعسكرية،
إذا ما أراد الناتو ضم أوكرانيا،
وإن انضمت أوكرانيا إلى الناتو
فسيرى الحلف ردا روسيا قويا،
(يقول بوتين فهمتم أم لم تفهموا،
إذا انضمت أوكرانيا إلى الحلف
وحاولت اقتطاع القرم من روسيا
فسنتدخل عسكريا وبقوة،
وسيتم جركم إلى هذه الحرب رغما عنكم،
ولن يكون لديكم القدرة على أن ترمش عيونكم
(عند اللجوء للبند الخامس)،
وينص البند الخامس عل أن
(من يعتدي على دولة في حلف الناتو
فذلك بمثابة على الاعتداء على الحلف كله)
وهو بذلك سيرد لا محالة...
فهل ينفذ الحلف هذا البند؟
أم أن الخوف من الدب الروسي
سيجعله مجرد حبر على ورق؟
ولماذا أطلقت روسيا تهديدا مباشرا هذه المرة؟،
بأنها سترد إذا تعرض مواطنوها للقتل
في أي مكان بما في ذلك دو نباس؟!!!
وهنا تواصل القوات المسلحة الروسية
مجموعة معقدة من الإجراءات
واسعة النطاق للتدريب العملي للقوات.
وتشارك فيها عملياً جميع المناطق العسكرية
والأساطيل والقوات المحمولة جواً.
ليخرج دميتري بيسكوف السكرتير الصحفي
للرئيس الروسي، ويقول:
أن "روسيا أجرت وستواصل إجراء التدريبات
في جميع أنحاء البلاد،
هذه عملية مستمرة،
كما هو الحال في جميع دول العالم.
هذا هو حقنا في إجراء التدريبات هناك،
على أراضينا، في المكان الذي نراه مناسبًا"
يبدو أن روسيا ماضية وفق إجراءاتها،.
وهنا يؤكد وزير الخارجية الروسي،
سيرغي لافروف، خلال اجتماعه
مع رئيس منظمة الأمن والتعاون في أوروبا،
زبيغنيف راو، عدم وجود بديل لتنفيذ اتفاقيات مينسك.
وبين هذا وذاك تجري
موسكو انسحابا مفاجئا لبعض قواتها،
فهل هو انسحاب مخادع،
وهو الهدوء الذي يسبق العاصفة؟
وزارة الدفاع الروسية تصرح:
وحدات من الجيش المتمركز في الجنوب والغرب
أنهت مهماتها وبدأت بالتحضير للعودة
وستتحرك إلى ثكناتها العسكرية اليوم،
وستعود قوات المشاة بمفردها
ضمن صفوف عسكرية"، حسب قولها،
لكنها أكدت أن التدريبات العسكرية الرئيسية
لا تزال مستمرة... فما الذي يجري حقا؟
فلم يعد أحد يستطيع التنبؤ
بما ستؤول إليه هذه الأزمة الروسية الأوكرانية؟
....